Why me, you know? Like being a model and
doing these things, like
>> [snorts]
>> I didn't think that I was good enough.
There's so much profound stories, and
this is why I think Islam is for the
sinners.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh. I'm so happy to be able to
talk to you [music] today.
And mashallah, my brother or Sheikh Ali
Hammuda is doing a great job. Waqf
Forever is a very, very
beautiful cause because [music]
the reward of what you give is not just
at the moment of giving, but rather it
is prolonged for a very, very long time,
>> [music]
>> and it lasts for as long as that waqf
continues to generate to generate some
form [music] of benefit. So, I highly
recommend Waqf Forever. As an ambassador
of Abdullah Aid, I know the the
partnership that we have is amazing.
>> [music]
>> And
not many people understand the concept
of waqf, yet the reward is far greater
through the waqf.
So, inshallah, if you can support Waqf
Forever,
>> [music]
>> it will be really, really amazing and
very, very rewarding.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. Hope you guys are well.
Inshallah, before the video starts,
there's going to be a link in the
description for you to get an Eid gift
to your Muslim friends, family members,
neighbors that are non-Muslim, or even
reverts. This amazing helpful Quran,
that's what it's called, the purple
Quran, and it's in purple, brothers and
sisters.
The most easiest read to have, brothers
and sisters, in simple plain English.
Alhamdulillah. Brothers and sisters,
this is a gift and an amazing strategic
way of giving dawah to non-Muslims. The
purple Quran, what is the purple Quran?
Brothers and sisters, you can get yours
with a discount code SALAH PRO. It's
£15, but you can get it for £10, and
there's only about 700 left in stock.
When it's gone, it's gone, isn't it?
There you go. So, oh. I was I was uh
I was sign languaging for you.
Perfect. So, this video that we're going
to react to, I found it very profound.
And there's so many lessons to learn out
of this because there's a lot of people
that are very judgmental. Okay, now
we're going to talk about judging.
People conflict two things.
Judging, we need to understand
something. We don't believe only God can
judge me. We can judge people from
apparent. For example,
>> by what's apparent, yeah. Yes, but let's
give context to that cuz when I see
these people go, "Well, don't you?" No,
I don't. Let me explain it. If someone's
drinking alcohol, we're not going to
say, "Oh, we don't know what's in his
heart." No, we're going to say he's
drinking alcohol, that's haram. If we
see a sister who's dressed up
inappropriately, we're going to say we
judge from what's apparent, that's
inappropriate. Where we don't cross the
line in judging, this is where it's uh
sinful judging, is that you see a woman
uh that what was it she looked at but
let's say she's dressed inappropriately,
and then you go, "Oh, she's probably a
prostitute."
>> Uh yes. Now you're crossing boundaries.
>> Or judging the intention, right? This is
and who they are. Oh, he drinks alcohol,
he probably robs people. Yeah. How did
you go from one to that? That is sinful
judging to judging from what's apparent.
Even when you do that, you can give
nasiha in a good way. This is Nelly Jay.
This is Nelly Jay. And you guys probably
know her. And her she is a bikini model.
She said this in the thing. She said
she's a bikini model, etc. She
acknowledges her sins. She knows that
it's wrong. But the point is greater
than that. The point is a woman who does
bikini modeling seeing the Prophet
Muhammad, you will see that like
nah. I'm so sorry. In Islam, I'll say
yes. Because this religion is for the
sinners. People that understand, Jannah
is full of ex-sinners. So, this religion
is not for the saints, by the way. Let's
make that very clear. Let's get into the
video cuz I'm going to mention some
profound hadiths that would uh it will
make you cry. Wallahi al Azim, the mercy
of Islam. Let's get straight into the
video. You ready? I am ready to rock and
roll. Let's do it.
I swear the amount of times I cried over
this story, just so happy and so proud
of you. So, I had to share this moment.
Let's take you back to the very
beginning. Let's rewind. We were all
holidaying, right? We were having a
fantastic family holiday. There was like
20 of us, right? And then we had to
leave and we went to Turkey, but then
you were in Thailand? You were with your
cousin? And what were you guys doing? Um
we were living it up.
>> [laughter]
>> What's living it up? What do you mean by
that?
>> we're Muslims at the end of the day. We
don't party, we don't drink, we don't do
that, but we're just living life like
we're soaking in the sun. I was in
bikinis. Like, you know, that's my job.
I was sitting outside. I was listening
to nasheeds.
And I was just crying. I always listen
to nasheeds and it's like one of my
favorite things. And my cousin and I
were on an island, deserted island. And
we were thinking about places to go
next. And for some reason, I don't even
know what it was. It was so out of the
blue. I can't even tell you till this
day. I just looked at her and I go,
"Jannah, what about Umrah? Like, why
don't we go to Umrah?" I I can't like
I'm genuinely telling you I can't even
explain why. Okay, here I just want to
stop you. This is very important because
I've had this experience in my life as
well, where you get this feeling
of doing something, but you don't know
where it came from.
Like, it's good stuff, obviously, you
know. Like wanting to come to Mecca,
come to the holy land, but something
just says to you,
"Just do this." Have you ever had that
experience, Revert? Yeah, 100%.
Literally performing Umrah like 2 weeks
ago. That was it. It was so spontaneous.
I'm just sitting there and I'm like,
"Bro, we we should do it." There was no
there was no planning, there was
nothing. It was just a spontaneous
thought.
>> Mhm. Interesting. Yeah, it really does
happen. So, this is Allah wants
something for you. You know what? Allah
looks in the hearts. Yes, you might
judge someone. That's why I say, guys,
never judge people based on how they
dress. Wallahi, I've seen women in our
dawah table. Sisters like I I think
they're non-Muslims talking to them. And
this sister dressed up inappropriately.
And wallahi, you know, even one of them,
especially to Canada, she knows. she was
saying I watch your videos may Allah
bless her etc. and preserve her. And we
gave her a guided prayer mat so she can
learn salah. And I asked her a question
and I said, "Sister, I said
you know you probably know a lot of
Quran, isn't it?" And she went like
"How do you know?" I said
"Because you know I don't judge the
opposite by oh you're dressed
inappropriately."
She know she probably she knows more
Quran than me. She knows 15 juz, bro.
Half of the Quran she's memorized. Even
though what she's doing is not
permissible, but the idea is don't judge
in the sense we And she knows she said
"Look brother, I know how I'm dressed
etc." I said to her I didn't even
mention it. I don't I didn't even go
there. I didn't come I'm not that type
of guy who
I know they know. I don't need to repeat
them and go "By the way, you're dressed"
They know it. I said I said "Sister,
look I I didn't even think of that. My
thing is just I thought you were a
non-Muslim I was giving the thing." She
didn't know how to pray salah or
something like that was lying on the I
can't remember. Gave her a mat. But
anyways, let's carry on. prepared to go
to Umrah?
Like not even the slightest. It sounds
bad for me to say. Obviously, just
before I was in bikinis and I'm like
I'm about to go do Umrah. Like what am I
supposed to wear? I can't wear bikinis
astaghfirullah. So you jumped on a plane
in Thailand
to Medina. Yeah. By yourself. I don't
even think grown men would do that. And
you didn't even know if your cousin were
coming at this point.
>> No. You jumped on that plane by
yourself. I didn't have a tour guide. I
I honestly didn't even really know what
to expect or what to do. How to How do
you perform a pilgrimage? It was like no
one could change my mind. I had this
feeling
I'm going to go. Why? Because I have it
in my heart and it's my invitation and
I'm just going to go. I'm not going to
deny Allah. Like that is all that I was
feeling. And I feel like alhamdulillah
like I have a really good sense of
reliance of Allah. I just knew that if I
would go that everything would be okay.
>> You called us and you were like
um I'm going to Umrah like today by
myself. My cousin's not coming. And I
was like, "Oh my god. She's going to be
there all by herself. What do we do?
Like So, I put a story online. I don't
know if you guys saw on my story, but I
put a story up on Instagram. It was
like, "Any sisters that are in Medina or
Mecca at this week, can you like DM me?"
I really loved that about Saudi. It was
such an eye-opening experience because
as my profession, you know, you
literally have to care about what you
look like. And you have to care about,
you know, everything. Your body, the way
that you eat, your exercise. It was so
refreshing because I didn't feel like I
was judged based on the way that I
looked. And that's why like I really
respect modesty. Being there made me
realize that they're more free than us.
What she just said here, bro, is
critical. And I talked to this in my
dowah table to many I've done a video
called Saudi girl
hijab or something like that. Got went
mega viral everywhere because she What
she just said now The latest what she
just said now is exactly because true
freedom is that, bro. The Western woman
are enslaved. Yes? At the end of the
day, look, we know she's a bikini model.
Allah subhana wa ta'ala forgive her. She
knows anyways. Bikini is underwear with
all due respect, bro. Bikini is just
change word of underwear. They put woman
in underwear. Sexual objectification.
Degrade Being degraded. And it's brought
the woman to be a mere sex object. So,
if you look at it, true freedom is what?
When you wear the hijab, you control
your sexuality. Number one, you don't
other women don't look at each other as
well cuz women are very like that in the
sense where they look out each other.
They're very in competition with each
other. You don't look at other person
can't see the other woman's body.
You get it? You can't see your beauty.
You can't see your hair. So, there's no
judgment between each other. There's no
gossip. There's no jealousy or whatever
it is that. Number two, when it comes to
obviously it doesn't attract men as
well. Obviously they both have to do
their part in that situation or whatever
it is. But true freedom is that. When I
speak to Western women and they're like,
"Oh, I choose to." I'm like, "You
telling me in this weather,
2 degrees, you're wearing a miniskirt
showing your cleavage, got heels, you've
took off your
your heels and you're carrying in your
hand. Why is it in your hand?
It's uncomfortable. It hurts your feet.
Your feet's bleeding right because you
How do you know?
Because it's enslavement. You're doing
things that you don't want to do. You're
doing it because society has programmed
you to make you feel as if you have to
do that because you want attention
whatever the the the the beauty
industry, the opposite gender,
Instagram, Netflix, you name it. They
are pushing you and that's why there's a
book I recommend Lily Jay and her
daughter to read called Beauty Sick. I
recommend every woman to read that, you
know? Um and there's another book called
Girls on Edge. It shows you the
depression and anxiety girls are going
through with this expectation in life. I
don't know if you if you know anyone
that's a 100% also cracks me up how
everyone's like, "Oh, the hijab and
dressing modestly oppresses women." When
you realize it actually liberates them
to the fact where men respect them for
who they are not for what they look
like, right? In the West, when you want
to date a girl or you want to get to
know a girl, you're going up to her
truly just because of how she looks. But
Muslim men, we're going for, "Okay, is
this person going to be a good mom? Do
they have a good dean? Do they have good
character? Do they have good morals and
values?" Right? So, you got to think,
men are respecting you more and not
judging you based on what you look cuz
bro, we got to boil it down. Men are
men. They see pretty thing and they go,
"Ooh, pretty." Changes completely how
they think, right? So, how do you know
people are actually being nice to you?
They just think you're pretty and
they're just treating you with kindness
versus when you're in an a cab and
someone treats you so nice and you know
they're treating you nice cuz they
respect you as a woman not because of
anything else not because of how you
look like not because of the shape of
your body not because of anything else
just because you're a woman and you're
supposed to be respected.
>> That's the wisdom of the Because the
thing is as men we can fall in love the
wrong way. And the way we men fall in
love the wrong in the wrong way is
because we can look at a woman be like,
"She's not my wife. I don't plan on
marrying her now. But she's got a nice
body. I just want her for the for the
her body." We men can fall in love the
wrong way because of the way we are
created. That's why Allah has stipulated
that so then it protects you where a man
seeing your face and he's talking to you
as a human being rather than be like,
"Oh, I'm not really interested in her
but she's got a nice whatever whatever
whatever." So, but yeah, anyways, let's
go to the most important bit here. We
are so confined in a little box,
stereotypes and beauty standards. Okay,
I'm going to show you where Rasulullah
is buried. And I'm like walking, and
she's like, "Look up, here it is." And I
was like,
>> [gasps]
>> I know. Like, [clears throat] I couldn't
even believe
or fathom that I was even in the
vicinity of where he was buried.
is right in front of us. I honestly feel
like that that is the happiest, like the
happiest I've ever felt in my life.
>> Subhanallah.
I don't even know. Like, it's so hard to
even explain it to people who hasn't Oh
gosh. When we went in there, like it was
so tranquil. It was so
beautiful. After we prayed, I looked to
my cousin, and I go, "Can you hear that?
Can you hear like the birds and like the
gushing of water?" And she goes, "Yeah,
I can."
Like Yeah, it was beautiful. It was like
these It was like these birds, and it
was like shh these It almost felt like a
river or a waterfall. Anyways, we end up
going up and meeting with our friend
Mickey's.
And I go to her, I go, "Sister, did they
put speakers in the router?" And she
goes, "No, what do you mean?" And we
look at each other, like me and my
cousin. And we go, "We heard like bird
sounds and, you know, like rushing
water."
And she goes, "What? I've been to the
router like four times, and I've never
heard that before. When I called you
guys and I spoke to my dad, he was
saying, 'Baby, if you get into this
place, and if you listen hard enough,
you can hear the river of Jannah.'"
Yeah. I
My jaw's on the floor. I was [laughter]
like,
"Oh my god, I can't even believe this."
That wasn't even like the best part.
>> Okay, what was it?
>> We were walking towards his grave, and
there was just this beautiful man, and
he was staring in the direction of
Prophet Muhammad's grave.
And I remember looking at him, and I
just like I was transfixed. He had so
much noor on his face. It perfectly
encapsulated what I thought Prophet
Muhammad would have looked like.
And I just kept walking. And then there
was another time, and I saw the guy
again. And I tried for my cousin to see
him. I'm like, "Oh, look, look, look,
that's him." She's like, "Where? Where?
I can't see him."
And I just kept having this feeling in
my heart that that was Prophet Muhammad.
This is here. It's very key, bro. You
know why? Because I'll be honest with
you, cuz I know
like people like sometimes exactly they
use this to be like, "Oh, you know, I'm
really holy. I saw the prophet in my
dream." You know, and I'm not saying
people are like lying. I'm not saying
that. I'm just saying that it can come
across as this like very cliche like,
"Oh, here we go, you know. Oh, he's seen
it as well." Before I came to when I
first became a Muslim, I didn't see the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam. Um I
saw someone. I didn't see like
him. And I knew it was the prophet.
That's all I know. I did not see him at
all. However, in my dream, I knew that
that was him.
I've got the dream interpreters anyways
for that for for that matter, but I did
I've never seen him. I've never seen him
in my dream. But I knew that person was
there. So, it's like Allah puts in your
heart and lets you know
that is him. You know? Subhanallah. So,
I don't know if you have the experience
once in your life.
>> Yes, the difference of like, "Oh, that
person looks like what would be Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him." Versus,
"No, I think I've seen him." Yeah,
there's a big difference. And and
knowing internally that's him. Like I've
had dreams where I'm like
bro, like
I know it's like in my heart I'm like,
this true is like someone's in my dream
I'm in this specific scenario that I
would if if if I knew I was in the
dream, I would have said, "Hold on a
second, that's not me. I don't do that.
That's not my life." Bro, I'm in a whole
living a whole different life, and I
know that I should be living that life.
I'm doing It's not me. It's not Ali in
the dunya. It's something else. Um it it
it's weird. It's weird. But yeah, let's
get to the main part because there's
really important reminders to take from
this. I was like, it can't be. Like,
he's not alive. And I'm going to his
grave. I'm like, that that it's just not
even possible. I honestly couldn't
believe my eyes. And I can still see him
like in my head even now when I think
about it.
>> Wow. Comes to find out, we're talking to
a chef.
>> [snorts]
>> And we're asking like, can't just
Prophet Muhammad come to you in your
dreams? And he's like, no. Like, he can
actually come to you as a form of a
human. And he goes, I think you saw the
prophet. Like, you saw him.
I'm like, no.
Like,
it's crazy even thinking about it now.
>> [snorts]
>> And I was like, no, I didn't. No, I
didn't. I can't [laughter] believe it.
I was like, how me? How like,
>> [snorts]
>> why me, you know?
Out of everyone.
Gosh, this feels so stupid.
I'm jealous. I want to see the prophet.
[laughter]
I was like, why me, you know?
>> [snorts]
>> Like, being a model and doing these
things. Like,
>> [snorts]
>> I didn't think that I was good enough.
Okay, here is critical, bro. Let me tell
you why. Islam, when we look at Islam,
like these kind of This is why you get
stupid, excuse me, or dumb Muslims who
they think
someone being accepted by Allah it's,
you know, it's it's it's all external.
What you look like, what you wear, what
you say, how you, you know, your beard,
your niqab. Well, that I do not believe
this, bro. These are things that are
sent. But, wallahi, if you look into the
Quran, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala talks
about taqwa. Taqwa is something
internal, it's not external. Taqwa is
internal. Yes,
what's internal should shine on the
outward as well. But, if you look in the
Quran, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
when you sacrifice an animal, it's not
the blood that reaches Allah, but it's
the taqwa. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says, the taqwa is not facing the east
or west. It's not a specific direction.
Allah says, we've sent the clothing to
protect your your your your your shame.
But, the taqwa clothing of taqwa is more
uh important. Allah Azzawajal in Surah
Tawbah talks about Masjid al-Darar, and
a masjid that was built for the munafiqs
to plot against Islam. And Allah says
it's better that you go pray in the
masjid of taqwa.
Taqwa, taqwa, taqwa, taqwa. From the
clothes that you wear to the direction
you face, and animal that you sacrifice,
um to the place that you pray. Taqwa is
something internal, bro. When Allah
looks at the heart and finds pure
hearts, clean hearts, s- like hearts
with peace that subhanallah, they don't
have any maliciousness against anybody,
cleanness. And that's why I believe the
story. You know why? Bro, there's so
much profound stories, and this is why I
say Islam is for the sinners. I'll give
you one scenario scenario of a Sahaba, a
companion, who drinks alcohol, bro, in
front of the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam. He's drunk. The companions,
they they lash him in public. They give
him lashes as a punishment. And this
happens so many times. One of the
companions in front of the Prophet says,
"May Allah curse you to the man."
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
says,
"Don't say that, for he loves Allah and
His Messenger." The Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam didn't say, "Oh, yeah,
yeah, he deserves that. It's good for
you." Why do you say it so late? You
should've said it earlier.
He got so angry and said, "Don't say
that. He loves Allah and His Messenger."
If that man was here today, Muslims
would have been charging him, "You
alcoholic, you're this, you're that."
Look at that. Number two, zina. A man
came to the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam and said, "Oh, Messenger of
Allah, make zina permissible for me,
brother." Meaning, make us Allah to make
zina halal, not haram. Did the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam say, "How
dare you in front of me? Kill him, take
him out." He sat him down and said,
"Would you want that for your mother,
sister, daughter?" "No, no, oh Messenger
of Allah, no."
Then don't do it to others. Look at the
mercy that he had. The man who was
weeing in in the mosque, he didn't know.
Did the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam beat him? No, the companions
were going to go attack him. He said,
"No, leave him. Let him finish." He
said, "Let him finish."
There could be two couple of reasons for
that, but he after he went, he gave him
advice. And I'll give you something that
will make you guys shiver.
A woman who comes to the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him. And you
know the capital punishment in Islam.
There's a capital punishment for
adultery. Yes?
Bro, look how Islam deals with people of
zina and those who commit prostitution.
On the other religions, you're doomed.
Bro, in Christianity, the woman is
blamed just because she's a woman. They
They would The church fathers were
discussing if she had a soul. Yeah?
Okay? The woman give childbirth, they're
in pain because of what Eve Eve done.
That's Christianity for you. Okay? Yeah.
So, now the thing is this. She comes to
the Prophet Muhammad and goes, "Oh
messenger of Allah, I have committed
zina. I'm pregnant and it's because of
zina." The Prophet said, "Yes. We can't
wait to give you the capital the
punishment and kill you."
The Prophet moved away from her. They're
trying to ignore what she's saying
basically. As if he didn't hear it. She
was insisting, "Oh messenger of Allah,
I've done zina and I want to cleanse
myself." She's saying, "I want to be
purified with that punishment." The
Prophet said, "Listen. You're pregnant.
Once you give birth, then we'll talk
about it." Imagine giving birth about 9
months a year.
She goes,
comes back. "Oh messenger of Allah, I've
given birth."
The Prophet doesn't want to do it.
Cuz it's self-confession.
The Prophet says, "Listen. Go and suckle
your child for 2 years." Cuz in the
Quran, it's 2 years.
And then come back. The Prophet is
basically saying, "Go and repent."
She goes and suckles her child. Brother,
after 2 years, she comes back and goes,
"I'm ready."
Bro, check this out.
They carry the punishment out for her
cuz she's adamantly requesting it. Look
at how Islam views these women that you
deem that society will label them all
kinds of stuff.
You know once they've done that,
some of the blood,
because of that capital punishment,
splatters on the shoe of one of the
companions.
And you know what he does?
He He looks at it with disgust, like,
"This woman of zina, her blood on my
shoe." Ugh. Mhm.
Do you know what the Prophet says?
He says, "Don't do that.
For wallahi,
her repentance
will be sufficient. If you took her
repentance, it would be sufficient for
the whole of Medina."
Bro, I'm getting goose wallahi, I'm
getting goose bumps, bro.
Wallahi al adhim, bro.
This is the messenger of Allah we
believe in, bro. This is the Islam we
believe on. That a woman who's committed
zina is a prostitute, she is honored.
She's honored. How?
The shoe Look, look. The Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said, "Her
repentance will be sufficient for the
entire um of Medina, bro."
That's why when I heard the story, I was
so touched, bro.
Because we think Islam is for the
sinners and the angels. Wallahi, this
religion is for the sinners. Kaaba that
we're in now is full of sinners. Jannah
is going to be full of sinners.
And Allah does not want you to be
sinless. Mhm. He wants you to
acknowledge your sin and repent. The way
she's crying, you can see repentance. A
condition of repentance is what? You're
remorseful. Bro, you can see that. You
can see I we ask Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
that she changes her ways. Yes?
And even if not, there's like I said
before, I believe there's a journey.
Yes, to observe perspective. I know
there's who misuse it and say, "Oh, it's
not a journey." Yes, because they were
attacking Akhi Ayman. Yes? And we know
exactly what he meant in context. There
are those who take advantage of it. And
I know there's hypocrisy as well, cuz
imagine if a man um came and said, "Oh,
I can't stop looking at women. It's a
journey." Nobody would accept that.
>> Yeah. But the point is this. Wallahi, if
you're a sinner,
Allah's doors are always open for you.
Don't ever feel like I'm worse, I can't
do this, etc. Wallahi, Allah to Allah it
is Allah loves more the genuine
sincerity of a repentant than the
arrogance of the self-righteous person
who walks and thinks he's God's gift to
Earth and is arrogant. Allah loves the
repentance of the sinner more. Mhm.
That's why I wanted to say, bro. I don't
have to say anything you like to say,
bro. Well, that was really, really
touched by this. And I genuinely believe
she she saw the Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam.
Three things. I have three things. First
is two questions for the audience and
and also for you as well.
What's the difference between a Muslim
in Jannah and a Muslim in Jahannam?
A Muslim in Jannah and a Muslim in
Jahannam, they're both sinners.
The Muslim in Jannah is the one who
repented. Yes. The one who asked for
forgiveness, right?
>> Exactly. That's who repented. Ex-sinner.
Who is the one who wants to make us feel
like we're not worthy of Allah's mercy?
Shaitan. Exactly. So, she said something
so crucial right here. She said, "Why
me?" Like, "I am not worthy." And that
is Shaitan that makes us feel like we're
not worthy. Who is Shaitan to say we're
not worthy of Allah's mercy? Allah can
forgive anyone. And there are so many
stories, so many hadiths, so many
references in the Quran. Every single
chapter except one, he calls himself the
most merciful. And you think you're too
far gone? That is not true. I I love to
reflect on the story of the prostitute,
the story of the prostitute who went to
Jannah for
giving water to the dog, right? You're
telling me that one act, giving water to
the dog, was enough for Allah to have
mercy on her for every single thing that
she's done. And you think you're too far
gone?
Being too far gone is doubting the power
of your creator. You you think the
creator of the heavens and the earth
can't forgive you?
That's all I have to say. In short.
>> that there, what you just mentioned, to
think that Allah will not forgive you is
a
It's the biggest sin that anything you
can do.
>> And you can point it to someone else
actually. It's Look, look. If you say
Allah will not forgive me, that is a
bigger sin than anything you can commit.
If you committed zina,
it's not as worse as you saying Allah
won't forgive you cuz you're denying an
attribute of Allah. You're basically
saying, "My sin is greater than Allah's
mercy."
Batil. So, anything that you commit to
repent, inshallah.
>> Other people as well. That's final thing
to add, right? Then we think we're all
righteous. Oh, why would Allah forgive
You decide who Allah forgives?
>> Who are you? Bro, [snorts] if if they
left me to the people, like these people
that don't like me, they'd throw me in
hellfire in two seconds, bro.
Alhamdulillah if Allah is my lord. May
Allah bless you guys kind of fantastic
input. I missed that point there.
Salam alaykum.
Just send this to a lot of your friends
and family members who are all sinners
upon Allah as a reminder. Goodbye.